I have this tweet from interactive polls
2022. this is interesting Iowa DeSantis
up 11 Trump down 15. New Hampshire to
Santa's 52 to Trump's 37 Florida
DeSantis 56 to Trump's 30. Georgia
DeSantis 55 to Trump's 35. are they
lying to once again get rid of trump or
is Ron DeSantis the new Star let's try
it this way what would you say the
negatives on DeSantis are because we can
all do negatives on Trump all day long
and we can all do the positives on
DeSantis very easily right it's pretty
much everything but so what would you
say the negatives of DeSantis are he
passed anti-free speech legislation the
BDS Florida the BDS stuff I think that's
pretty important
okay what can you explain that
um I'm not that well read on it
specifically uh so I wouldn't want to
talk outside of my expertise to be
honest with you it was uh so boycott
divest sanction Israel yeah he came out
in favor of not allowing that I think it
had to do with universities but again
well not allowing it as a state actor
right all right so it sounds like we
don't fully understand what it is but
all right let's and that's okay okay so
but I'm not I'm not even coming out uh
as that as a principle negative for
DeSantis mostly because it's not
something I know enough about to
criticize him on admittedly we
definitely want to make sure we check
into something like that because sure he
was infringing if he was infringing on
any free person's speech then I would
have problem with it but the government
is allowed to tell government employees
what they're allowed to do something
like that so I would need to know this
was based in University and school
specifically if a school would support
or allow someone to to criticize or
boycott Israel he would punish the
school and take away their funding but I
think it had to do with and Donald Trump
also had similar points of views and
viewpoints that he also supported as
well so it's it's it's it's a trump uh
DeSantis issue I'll put it this way I
think we are all too uh weekly versed on
the issue specifically but I do think
it's important let's say let's even say
it was a pretty bad thing so okay to
entertain the possibility that there are
things we don't like about them that
were not well versed on I think is a
fair point however my view of DeSantis
is to be honest I can't think of a
negative however when you compare to
Santa's two Trump in in the event that
they go up against you know
um when they're on the stage Trump is an
imposing figure of grandeur who can uh
the way Milo put it is that when he gets
his mojo back he dominates the stage He
commands he pushes everyone out he shuts
him down now that is not a policy yes or
a practical Advantage it is a political
Advantage right so what's interesting
about that so I I actually agree with
you on that
um but he didn't really dominate Biden
in the debates and isn't that bizarre
now now knowing the degradation of Biden
and how bad he is and it was obvious he
was bad at the time but he didn't really
crush him in those debates so for some
reason Trump seems to be better when
there's multiple people on stage and
there's a Fray right and he can then
just sort of hit everybody but the
one-on-one thing was not his thing but
but also if at the end of the day the
the biggest weakness is that yes is
Trump more of uh I'm gonna get in the
ring with you and say all of the
horrible things and dig up all of the
evil [ __ ] and all of that to me I don't
know that most people see that as a
positive anymore I think people would
actually look at it and be like wait a
minute Trump what you're trying to do
here is take out the guy who has done
absolutely everything right using just
all of the worst tactics I just don't
know that that would fly anymore I like
what you said earlier when we were
downstairs in the Green Room you said uh
4D chess by mail it's the longest yeah
well that's everything with him is 4D
chess and it's like okay guys are we
gonna ever like does the game ever end
here I know a couple days ago I tweeted
oh no the 4D chess analogies are back on
online and I'm just like I I'm so sick
Trump is so Advanced he surpassed M
Theory yeah you want extra Dimension did
you throw out a tweet every now and
again where I have to read it like six
times and then I'm like all right forget
this I don't know which way he's going
on this one that was one of them I was
like what is going on here is it 12d now
like where are we going but but not
Trump also came out a few days ago and
says that he has dirt on DeSantis that
his wife doesn't even know that he's
going to be releasing to the general
public he said this on Fox news but
that's what it is even if it's true even
if it's true right whatever it is he
cheated on his wife and he did blow off
a hooker's ass and like whatever it is
political Behavior first off Trump's
done an awful a lot of bad stuff and I
just don't think if if you're willing to
do that now to the guy that's getting
everything done right it's like I just
don't think that's what Americans want
anymore I think there is a Long Leash on
our personal lives and that we've all
done stuff Trump proved it right Trump
proved you can sleep with hookers and
you can grab them by the [ __ ] and you
can do all that stuff and we'll still
vote for you so if his move is well
DeSantis has done kind of all the policy
right so I can't get him on that but I'm
gonna dig up something to derail him I
think it's going to have more blowback
than and it has and it has right now
especially with these numbers that that
Tim is showing but also I would question
the numbers because the numbers in the
polls have been wrong a lot but the
conversation in my opinion should be the
anti-establishment versus McCarthy
McConnell but it's not it's the
anti-establishment versus The
anti-establishment Wing of the party
kind of having a civil war within each
other destroying each other rather than
of course building and growing and of
course fighting the bigger fights out
there fighting themselves and
essentially eliminating and destroying
any potential of a populist surge that
that could be there well to that point I
mean we don't even know if census is
going to run I mean the guy loves
Florida like I honestly I know him
fairly well now and I've done a bunch of
things with him like the guy freaking
loves the State of Florida
he loves it look what he's done there
like maybe in part of his head he's like
hey I'm 44 years old I got this
beautiful young family like I'm riding
high right now maybe my life is to just
fortify the place that I love and do
great things they're like we don't know
what his plan but when he was asked
directly he gave a perfect political
answer not answering the question
during the debate as Governor which made
it seem exactly like he's going to be
running like any politician so let me
give you some Insider context on that I
was actually at the debate and right
before the cameras started they
announced to the crowd that was in the
room they said the candidates have
agreed and signed a document saying that
they will not ask each other questions
so when DeSantis just stood there it was
because he was honoring what they signed
Charlie Crist has no morals and and or
anything else so Charlie Chris knew
exactly what he was doing that's not to
say DeSantis shouldn't have had a better
response he should have said no well he
should well or he could have said hey
Charlie we actually just signed
something that said we're not going to
do that do you have any do you have any
morals do you have any we we talked
about it when it happened we did the
math on it uh there's no upside
to doing anything other than saying no
right if if he said are you if he said
are you going to run for president or
what he said was are you gonna uh commit
to finishing out your term as Governor
does Andrews could have went yes I do
thanks Charlie have a nice day and just
end it yeah because if in the event in
the future things change he can say
something like I know I vowed to be here
for the State of Florida but I decided I
can be as the President of the United
States I can do more for Florida and for
the rest of this country and I will make
sure that Florida stays true you know
say with my heart I think that advice
probably would have been better than to
he sort of did just freeze in the moment
but he was trying to honor the agreement
that they had just signed and you know
that's the problem when you when you
play with one guy that has rules you
know what Trump would have done
well what would travel done
if he was asked are you going to honor
your uh commitment to be Governor Trump
would have been like I thought we agreed
we weren't going to ask each other
questions when did you stop beating your
wife Charlie yeah exactly he would have
done something like that
that would have worked in the debate
context so your your point basically is
that even if DeSantis has everything
right and let's say let's just say
minimal uh downside it's like he might
get just crushed in the theater of the
thing that's that that is but but it is
possible it is possible imagine it's
really crazy I was watching um you know
we're playing music videos downstairs in
the green room we have that voice
activated TV that that you didn't like
yeah what are you doing thank you thank
you Dave I've been screaming about this
I was like the cia's listening every
single day
you Tim pool of all people you're
talking to your Google television it's
one TV in the whole house
that 20 of you are standing in coming up
with your plans to take
when we play the music videos these
these political ads would pop up where
they're just lying and it's the craziest
lies I've ever heard and I'm just
thinking to myself how do they get away
with saying things that are so look I
get it you can have your opinion in
politics and it's hard you know you've
got times to be Sullivan defamation
precedent stuff but when you come out
out Ryan be like my opponent said X and
he didn't it's just kind of a crazy
thought
I'm just like you know what I want to
see just look Republicans if you're
going to win right now you can do two
things you can play the game of lies or
you can offer fifteen thousand dollars
to everybody who votes for you like Joe
Biden did basically but I'm imagining
you go up on stage and pull pull the
play the game are you gonna stay and
commit to being Governor when did you
stop beating your wife when did you stop
touching your children you want to play
games let's ask I I didn't say he did I
asked him when he stopped that's that's
that's that's the level of politics
right and people will immediately
believe it even though you didn't say he
did you can say when when did you stop
stealing from the local grocery store so
in a way you're making an argue you're
making an anti-trump argument I think
because your argument basically is he
could open maybe he sort of did this and
it needed to happen the person but he
might open up the gates of hell here
right like if it gets to the two of them
and it's like DeSantis is winning on
policy and you know it he feels fresher
and it's right and there's a track
record but Trump is willing to do the
craziest [ __ ] known to man which I think
we would all agree we would do and again
I voted for the guy and I think you
right so that says some that says
something about Humanity I suppose it
does and it's something very dark
you know
Ben Shapiro he says facts don't care
about your feelings quite assuredly he
does and he gets a hundred plus thousand
retweets on Twitter he pins it and all
of the conservative smugly pet each
other on the back in their victory of
how smart they are in reality and but
they're not wrong they're not wrong but
but I say this rather aggressively
because
feelings don't care about your facts and
you can come out and say well if Joe
Biden were to shut down the Keystone
Pipeline it would cause speculative
Drive meaning the the investors and the
Traders are going to realize Supply
won't meet demand in the coming years
because the pipeline was shut down and
thus prices will increase so the invest
now causing an early price increase and
the average person goes huh and then Joe
Biden comes out and goes look at here
man I'm gonna give you ten thousand
dollars you know put in your body come
on man and they go well ten thousand
dollars sounds pretty good I'll vote for
him
keep it simple make it understandable
Donald Trump gets on a debate stage with
Ron DeSantis and Ron says in the great
state of Florida we kept our businesses
open we saw our economy improve
unemployment went down and Trump's going
to go well I think you're ugly and
everyone's gonna go whoa parents are
clapping and cheering I know and I'm I
think personally I'm just past that part
and that I mean that may be where we're
at like I think we need enough how about
something like this I think we just need
more adults in the room I think too many
of us have just let go of that uh part
of ourselves in a way did not want to
confront all of the scary mean things
out there and maybe we just need a
little more of Jordan Peterson like like
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and and just not be part of the
slow descent to hell I think that's true
I'm wondering if anyone could get into
the presidency and not get assassinated
acting like Kennedy be like the CIA I'm
uncovering at all they they know where
the guy lives like so is it more of a
local adulthood that you're trying to
create well I think DeSantis could like
I don't want any of these guys to get
assassinated even the ones I don't like
but you know I think that there is room
for a sane competent person I think if
we had a same competent person as
president and we do not have the same
competent person right now and Joe Biden
if we had someone who people believed he
believed what he was saying and was
roughly honest and things kind of worked
I think people would let go of so much
of the other [ __ ] happening in society
right now but right now we know it's
what you just said we know everything is
a lie everywhere constantly everything
that they say is misinformation usually
is truth all the good guys are the bad
guys the bad guys the good guys so
people are willing to do anything thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time